today we're going to review the big exam
that we recently did
on complex numbers and the nature of
proof so we're going to go through each
question
uh try and be as detailed as possible
and also look at one of my favorite
things
which is when you've got multiple
different solutions for a problem
looking at all the different ways why
you would prefer one way over another
and uh you know try and unpack the many
different problem-solving approaches
that are relevant to an exam like this
now before we get going it is really
important to note that in the sequence
of how we've learned and assessed you
within this course
this is a pretty tough exam at least i
felt it was that way
when i was writing it it was tough for a
couple of reasons number one
if we have a think about complex numbers
which is the first topic that's sort of
assessed in this and you can see it
right here on the page
we've already assessed you on complex
numbers having learnt a lot of that
last year in fact however this test
looked at that same topic but because
we've already assessed some of the basic
stuff earlier
we kind of were left with some of the
more challenging material here so
you might have felt like you didn't have
much of a gentle introduction
to this topic in the assessment task and
that was by design
because we kind of already did that in a
different exam so that's the first thing
that makes this challenging
and the second thing that made this
challenging was the topic the nature of
proof
it is in many regards even though it is
built on the foundation of so many
things you've learned in other topics
and in other courses within mathematics
in many ways is kind of the most foreign
to a lot of people
uh you know it's it's not like when you
were doing all of your calculus you can
learn a set of steps
set algorithms formulas and then off you
go you could rely on things like the
reference sheet to aid your memory
the nature of proof topic even though
every topic does this a little bit
the nature of proof topic particularly
requires a lot of
abstract and creative thinking that
characterizes mathematics
as a whole but maybe uh you know isn't
is emphasized as much as some of the
other topics so
that might be a muscle in your brain
that just is a little bit weak
and that's why you particularly found
this assessment task challenging so
that's why
when you got your papers back there's a
huge range in the marks that you
received and
regardless of whether you got high or
low marks you've all got a lot to learn
from doing this task and from reviewing
it carefully so that's what
this is going to be about we've got the
question paper in front of us right here
so
i'm going to do my best to unpack each
one i've also got the written solution
which which i'm going to refer to
and emphasize some different bits here
and there but why don't we dive in to
the very first question
in multiple choice it says
which diagram best represents the
solutions to this equation provided here
and then you've got your four choices a
b
c d all right now the first thing to
have a think about is what does this
particular equation tell us
what does it mean and therefore from the
basis of that we can then interpret
which is the most appropriate diagram
right and there's two arguments
being compared and it's the arguments to
some you know movable point zed which
presumably can sit somewhere on the
graph that gets drawn
and what we're doing is we're measuring
the argument to that point
from a couple of different locations
what i often call
reference points right now if you think
about this one the reference point here
is kind of plain
arg said means the reference point
you're thinking about is the origin
what is the angle measured from the
positive real direction
from the origin to z so if i you know
let's just draw something messy up here
like if i said oh here's a point
what is x we're pretty familiar with
this we start from the origin
and we look up from the positive real
direction
and we say oh that that theta right
there that would be
argo of that particular z so what we
want is
to compare that argument this one that
i've drawn as theta here
with this argument now what does this
mean it will be helpful if we rewrite it
actually
um it'll be it's more clearly written as
arg
of zed take away now you just got to be
careful because you've got some
double negatives lying around here it's
going to be
negative 1 plus i
just double check that i did that right
you can see these two negatives will
become the plus 1
and that minus and that plus become the
negative so
looks like this is correct so negative 1
plus i this
is our other reference point if you
wanted to write it to make it really
explicit over here
this would be arg of z take away
0 the origin right so reference point 1
is the origin
reference point 2 is negative 1 plus i
we're measuring from each of these
particular spots
so if for example i would just say on
you know this is my i've just
made up some stuff on this particular
diagram here if i said well where is
negative 1 plus i presumably that's
that's somewhere around let's use a
different color
it's somewhere around here so i would
again go from the positive
real direction and i would say well when
i
look up towards that that z where i am
this would be the theta or actually i
shouldn't call it theta it's called phi
because even on visual inspection you
can see
these two angles here are clearly not
the same size so so this spot up here
it doesn't work it's not going to
satisfy this equation because the
arguments
are different once theta wants phi just
by measuring you can see they're
different
so i'm looking for those series of
points or that collection of points or
the subset of the complex plane such
that when i do this kind of measurement
i'm going to get the same thing okay now
what i can then say let's get rid of
this because it's irrelevant now
what i can say is those two reference
points reference points the origin
and negative 1 plus i they are going to
figure on one of the diagrams right
actually multiple of them and i can
exclude those ones that don't include
the origin and negative 1 plus i
now every single one of these diagrams a
b c
and d they all include the origin so
therefore i'm now thinking about which
ones include
negative 1 plus i and which ones don't
negative 1 plus i where is that it's
going to be
negative in the real direction and then
positive
in the imaginary direction so you can
see i'm sitting up here
in the second quadrant so that's why i
can say
hold on a second this this doesn't have
negative 1 plus i
in it that looks to me like it would be
1 minus i to get there
and by the same token and this one over
here doesn't have negative one
plus i in it so now the question is well
it's going to be
one of these two isn't it so which one
now you me may be able to at this point
already recognize oh i reckon
i i sort of think that this particular
equation is going to give me this kind
of shape
and if you instantly recognize it great
but some of you didn't you might think
okay well which one is it going to be
c or d both of them have the required
reference points on there
how do i determine this well i'm going
to do the same thing that i did before
which was to
take some point imagine it on this
particular subset of the complex plane
and then i'm going to see
does it work out am i going to get the
same argument from both directions
let's have a look at part c or option c
here if i were to pick some arbitrary
point on
this subset that's been identified what
arguments will i get measuring from
my independent reference points well
measuring from the origin i'm going to
get this angle here
that's theta right so if i look at my
other reference point negative 1 plus i
which is up here in the second quadrant
if i draw my positive real direction
there
and then i measure toward you know here
is
me looking toward my z you can see this
is the angle down here
it's going in a whole different
direction this angle can't possibly
be the same in fact you can already
determine that it would be
these two would be supplementary but
because i'm taking into account the
direction that i'm going in i'm going
fire's going clockwise rather than theta
which is going anti-clockwise
um they're not only going to be not
equal one's gonna be positive one's
gonna be negative right at least if i'm
considering
principal arguments so for this reason i
can say yeah this is this is not it
either it's not going to be c
the only one that's plausible is d and
maybe you already looked and you said oh
i know what this is going to be
this is going to be one of those ones
with with opposing rays um
where i sort of extend the interval that
i've got here and then i exclude sort of
the middle part
and you can test this very easily you
can say well let's let's pick a point
on this subset of the complex plane what
is augs n
if this is my z what is augz going to
look like here
it would be this angle theta what would
r
of z uh minus
1 plus i did i get that right plus 1
minus i
measured from negative 1 plus i what
would that look like
and again i will say let's draw my
positive real direction
in here i will measure you know imagine
myself
looking over at points n you say oh what
is this angle here
and because these are corresponding
angles on parallel lines because my
positive real directions are always
parallel you can say oh that is also
theta
so my auxed which is which is here
and my arg of z plus 1 minus i which is
here
they're equal this is going to satisfy
every point along here is going to be
giving me those same two arguments and
you could extend this doing it on the
other side so that is how i determined
that d is the correct answer all right
happy times that's question one let's
move on to the next one let points p
q and r represent the complex numbers uh
little p which is 2 plus 4 i little q
which is
negative 3 minus i and little r 4 minus
3 i
respectively which displacement vector
is represented by the complex number
negative 2 plus 7i all right now
if you are confident with your vectors
and you can visualize
an argan diagram you know you can
visualize the complex plane fairly
happily in your mind
you may well be able to just simply look
at this and answer the question
immediately but maybe you couldn't
because you looked at this and thought
i'm not 100
sure what this means so let's unpack the
important language here right
this thing here this displacement vector
is obviously going to be crucial because
all of the objects you're presented as
options for this question
they're all vectors so what does it mean
to be a displacement
vector well if i draw myself a little
argon diagram over here
a displacement vector is simply to say
how do i get from
one spot to another what kind of
you know horizontal and then vertical
displacement which corresponds to the
real part and the imaginary part of a
complex number
what do i need to undergo in order to
get from one point like say
a to another point say b now the way
that i would do that is i would say oh i
in this case i'd have to go to the right
some amount
and then i would have to go upwards some
amount that's going to take me from a
all the way over to b so
if for example in this particular made
up thing right if this distance
down the bottom was say 6 and this
distance was 3
then going 6 units horizontally
in a positive direction that would be
you know plus 6
and then if i were to go 3 units upwards
in the imaginary direction that would be
plus
3i so in this case the displacement
vector represented by this complex
number
would be a b and i could reverse that
right i could just as easily say
what if i looked in the opposite
direction what if i wanted to go from b
to a well just using my same colors here
i would have to go
6 but in the negative horizontal
direction and then i'll have to go 3
again but in the
negative imaginary direction so in this
case i would say
ba is going to be negative 6
minus 3i that would be the appropriate
complex number
that would take me 6 that way 3 that way
okay so that's what we're trying to
understand
here once i get that i just need to
think about well
carrying on to the rest of the question
negative 2 plus 7i
which pair of complex numbers can i get
from one to the other
by going 2 in the negative
real direction so that's to the left and
then 7 in the positive
imaginary direction so that's seven
units upward
so which combination you know between
this one this one and this one
and you know going which way changes the
the signs of what i've got
which one means uh go to the left to go
upward
seven so at this point i'm going to draw
on the fact that i've already written
these solutions up
so uh we saw question one already let's
just sort of shift that over a little
bit that was question one
so you see me picking option d and then
here's question
two so what i've done is i've positioned
p and q
and r according to the information in
the question let's just
zoom in a teeny bit there i know it's
made it very small hopefully you can
still read it
and when you see the picture in front of
you you know which how do i get from one
to the other that
means go to the left two and go upward
seven it is fairly easy to make the
argument
okay that's going to be this one here
that's going to the left two units
and then going upwards seven units so
it's from
r to p which is uh again
option d so two questions that were um
option d in a row okay so that's how i
read that um and you can see
um you've got you know there are other
distractions there if you read
the the order of the points wrong or if
you've got the signs
mixed up that's how i got from from this
point
going backwards up this way up to p that
gives me the result rp